welcome to our week six it's time to
negotiate the next generation social
contract so I'm looking forward to
really exciting and fruitful week all
the instructions are now on the platform
on week six so all you need to do is to
go to it you'll see instructions for how
to find your team your role assignments
then you go through and you'll complete
the preparation survey you'll negotiate
online with your counterparts hopefully
in the same time zone where you are
located and then as you complete the
survey form at the end to record your
settlements those of you who are taking
the course for certification and for
grade will get some extra credit as
described on the platform so we're
excited about it we're looking forward
to hearing what you have in mind for
shaping the future of work as a bonus we
will provide a facilitator one of our
MBA students what we call our community
TAS will be assigned to your group what
is a facilitator a facilitator is just
what that term sounds like it's a
neutral person it's a person who helps
move you through the process without
influencing your proposals or the
particular terms of the agreement that
you reach so this individual will help
you in scheduling times or answering
questions and be a liaison back to the
rest of us as needed so use the
facilitator at your choice and we'll see
how all of this works the deadline is
Thursday at the end of the day UTC time
1159 p.m. so it's important that you and
your teammates work on an agreement when
to negotiate engage in the course
discussion has instructed and we'll see
what we learn from this experience next
week is the grand finale of this course
and we have a special event it's called
a live video event or video chat
whatever one wants to call it on Tuesday
May tenth
at UTC time 8pm we will have an hour and
a half live interaction with all of you
where we will summarize what we have
taken away as the key lessons from this
course and we will incorporate the
materials not only from the course but
also your materials from the polls that
you completed surveys the assignments
that you did the discussions that you've
had on the forum all of this will come
together and with your engagement
directly by passing on questions to us
or comments as we go along for an hour
and a half we will see what did we learn
from this where are we going and how can
we use all of this material effectively
not only for yourselves but for external
audiences who are also interested in
shaping the future of work so please put
this on your calendar be ready with
questions or comments will send you
information next Monday the day before
this event on how to tune in how to wear
to link in for this interesting I hope
interesting and informative wrap up for
the course let me make a special request
of you to make sure that we bring your
voices into this process one segment of
the summary will ask the question what
is our key message to the future leaders
who will shape the future of work
business leaders and HR professionals
labor leaders and their advocates
government policymakers and those of us
in the education field so make sure that
on the discussion board this week where
we will post questions or a place where
you can add your thoughts to each of
these stakeholders that you bring your
voice into this process and will
incorporate that into the discussion
next week tuesday so i look forward to
seeing what you have on your mind and
what message you want to deliver to
these groups who will help to shape the
future of work last week we had a very
very rich and engaging discussion and in
fact throughout this course many of you
commented on the subject for last week
and that is what's the future of labor
is there still a need for labor
organizations for unions as we've called
them over many years and in fact over
several centuries is a new form of
representation are there new ways and
which workers can get a voice at work
and assert their interests and work with
their employers to shape the future of
work most of you do see the need for
some form of labor representation maybe
not for everyone but for the people who
really want to have a collective voice
at the workplace but you also see the
need for change and for innovation to
build on the strengths of what unions
have done historically for so many
workers around the world you talked
about the need to expand more
labor-management partnerships like the
one out at Kaiser Permanente that we
discussed many of you are focused in a
very rich dialogue over the need for
what you call digital unions that is
using information technology social
media and related mechanisms to convey
your ideas and to communicate with each
other across the world and indeed you
talked about the need for global unions
because obviously today where people
work how people are affected by jobs
that are created by companies around the
world is not simply a national issue
some of you talked about the need to
return to these interesting
organizations called guilds where
workers came together cooperatively to
enhance their profession or their
particular occupation and to work to
enhance their professionalism you talked
about the need for apps to share
information on where good jobs are in
good employers are along the lines that
we used in the good job survey that some
of you have done and then many of you
talked about the need for new forms of
advocates for low-wage workers in the
United States in Europe in developing
countries all around the world
particularly focusing on the role that
NGOs are now playing so I think the
bottom line of all of this don't just
observe these trends get involved
whether it's working
on the side of advocates for labor
whether it's enriching and strengthening
the role that HR plays in our
organizations whether it's thinking
about the future of labor policy in our
countries or whether you're like me
working in the education sphere either
on the university level with outside
world all of you in this global based
online course or our students in high
schools and community colleges we all
have a role to play we've emphasized
that throughout this course now it's
time for us to put our ideas to work so
I look forward to a very invigorating
week of negotiations will summarize the
settlements that were that are achieved
next week when we come together and
we'll see if we can't really summarize
and bring together what did we learn
what are the key takeaways from our
efforts to shape the future of work